أحد الأشياء التي
سيتعين على المستشار الخاص روب هير القيام بها
هو أن يحدد مع فريق بايدن
ما إذا كان هناك أي مكان آخر
يحتاجون إليه للبحث الآن نحن نعلم أن
عائلة بايدن قد استأجرت منزلاً في
فرجينيا أه خلال أه خلال  إحدى
الفترات التي نتحدث عنها هنا
، والسؤال هو أنك تعرف هل يجرون
بحثًا هناك أو أي مكاتب
أخرى ربما يكون قد استخدمها خلال ذلك الوقت
ومن يقوم بعمليات البحث هذه هل تريد
من مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي أن يقوم بها  أم أن البيت الأبيض
سيحضر ربما شخصًا لديه
أه لديه تصريح أمني يمكنه
إجراء عمليات البحث ويمكنني أن أخبرك
من جانب وزارة العدل أنه
كان هناك الكثير من الذعر حقًا بشأن
بعض الجدول الزمني هنا إذا كنت
تتذكر  مرة أخرى في الثاني من تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) ، عندما
يتم العثور على المستندات الأولى ،
يبدأ التحقيق ويبدأ التقييم
، وبعد ذلك يمكنك التخطي إلى
20 كانون الأول (ديسمبر) وهو الوقت الذي يتم فيه العثور على الدفعة الثانية
من المستندات.
تعرف على البيت الأبيض أه
وبالتأكيد أخبر فريق بايدن
وزارة العدل أنهم
سيقومون بعمليات البحث هذه ، لماذا استغرق الأمر
خمسة أسابيع أمر غامض ومن
ثم بالطبع ترى هذا الجدول الزمني
هناك في 9 يناير 9 ، 11 ، 12 و
الرابع عشر عندما طرح البيت الأبيض وفريق بايدن
روايات مختلفة لما
حدث هنا بالضبط